now dr wolinski's recommendations have
not won praise from all public health
experts for more on the debate that's
going on we're joined by cbs news
contributor dr celine gander she's also
editor at large for kff's kaiser health
news good to see you celine gallander
let's start with this how big of a deal
is it to hear the cdc admit listen we
made serious mistakes especially since
we all count on the cdc to get this
right
gail i think it's really important
because acknowledging the weaknesses
acknowledging that not everything went
right really does pave the way for
people at the cdc as well as more
broadly to change direction to correct
course and to do better in the future
so how do you build the trust back
because a lot of people are very
skeptical
well i think there are a couple
different things which are related to
some of the weaknesses we saw over the
course of the pandemic one is having
better
real-time access to data so data
dashboards that really give you a sense
of what's happening where you live in
real time
uh that was not available and that was
something that we many of us were asking
for
the the cdc has been very good at
publishing uh high level scientific
papers but that's a different kind of
data crunching analysis than we're
talking about here the other one is
communication and really
valuing communication is one of the most
important tools of public health
having a workforce that is trained to do
that specialized in doing that and also
uh keeping up with 21st century
communications approaches so that
includes things like social media uh all
the way down to uh in-person town hall
events and so really
improving the the full range of options
for communicating with the public
all right dr celine gander as always
it's great to see you thank you very
much